[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace andino desde
venezuela este programa estará dedicado
a la libertad de prensa a propósito del
día mundial que se celebra el 3 de mayo
explicaremos la situación de los medios
de comunicación y de la seguridad de los
periodistas en la nación suramericana
que han sido blanco de ataques durante
las últimas dos décadas también
hablaremos sobre la constante ola de
bloqueos que sufren medios digitales que
no siguen la línea del gobierno de
nicolás maduro en un país en el que los
periódicos físicos prácticamente no
existen y en el que los venezolanos
tienen cada vez menos medios para
informarse
son más de 20 años con patrones de
restricciones a la libertad de prensa en
venezuela en los que se mantienen la
descalificación de medios y periodistas
por parte del gobierno según la ong
espacio público en los últimos tres años
ha aumentado la persecución criminal y
se han abierto procedimientos judiciales
no sólo a periodistas también hay en
ciudadanos
según el último informe publicado por la
ong espacio público un tercio de las
violaciones a la libertad de prensa en
venezuela se traducen en
descalificaciones públicas el otro
tercio son casos de violencia contra
periodistas hay una política contra los
comunicadores basada en intimidaciones y
amenazas en la actualidad una docena de
periodistas están sometidos a procesos
judiciales de diversos tipos mildred
manrique ejerce del periodismo en
venezuela desde hace 14 años cuenta que
tiene en su cuerpo varias cicatrices por
agresiones en medio de coberturas de
protestas antigubernamentales
en marzo de 2014 su residencia fue
allanada por la guardia nacional y sus
equipos confiscados en julio de 2021
cerca de una decena de funcionarios
policiales encapuchados con armas largas
golpearon de nuevo a su puerta esta vez
no ingresaron a la vivienda sólo fue
intimidación
de 20 perdigonazos tengo las piedras y
en partes del cuerpo tengo cuatro
impactos de bombas lacrimógenas 2 en las
piernas
el hombre yo no en el pecho
el del pecho afortunadamente tenía un
chaleco antibala solo fue el hematoma en
el momento las demás y tengo cicatrices
exactamente muchas fueron aquí y también
recuerdo como la policía
venían en motocicleta y me agarraba por
el cabello y me arrastraba que en el año
2017 la asamblea nacional constituyente
aprobó la ley contra el odio según los
defensores de la libertad de expresión
esta norma es un instrumento para
censurar controlar y sancionar a
periodistas medios y hasta ciudadanos
particulares como ocurrió en el mes de
abril con una venezolana de 72 años que
fue imputada por supuestas amenazas a
nicolás maduró a través de un vídeo de
'tik tok' entretanto los medios para
informarse cada vez son menos de los 110
periódicos que existían en venezuela
apenas quedan alrededor de 10 y no
circulan todos los días la falta de
entrega de papel por parte del gobierno
y el impedimento de importarlo hizo que
la mayoría de los medios migraron
obligatoriamente al mundo digital en el
país existen alrededor de 960 medios de
comunicación incluyendo páginas web el
85% de ellos son emisoras de radio de
estaciones de televisión que son los
medios más hablados por el gobierno
durante las protestas
antigubernamentales entre 2014 y 2017 la
mayoría de los canales internacionales
de noticias fueron sacados de las
cableras por orden de conatel el ente
regulador
hoy en día tú puedes conseguir un canal
de noticias en inglés o en ruso o en
otro idioma pero en español no entonces
los medios que hacían cobertura fueron
perseguidos que fue emergieron algunos
medios que están basados en distribución
vía internet desde el año 2014 la
censura medios de comunicación en
internet ha crecido de manera
exponencial entre enero y diciembre de
2021 la organización med es sin filtro
reportó el bloqueo 59 páginas web 36 de
ellas correspondían a páginas de
noticias
césar batiz director del pitazo cuenta
que los continuos ataques al medio que
representa fueron acciones llevadas a
cabo justo después de la publicación de
reportajes de investigación contra altos
funcionarios de la administración de
nicolás maduró especialmente en materia
de corrupción
es una forma muy sutil que afecta por lo
menos a 36 medios de acuerdo a los
últimos reportes que conocemos medios
digitales que surgieron a partir del año
2014 e incluso antes de que se trata del
bloqueo esto genera que el venezolano
que es usuario de las plataformas de
estas empresas no tenga acceso a la
información que publicamos entonces esto
impide que la gente forme su opinión en
medio de este panorama sin periódicos
físicos y con medios digitales
bloqueados los venezolanos cada vez
tienen más limitaciones para informarse
acuden a las redes sociales a los
canales internacionales de noticias a
través de youtube y a unas pocas
emisoras radiales que logran burlar la
censura gubernamental
tú empiezas a buscar las emisoras nuevo
aquí no han dicho nada que no han dicho
nada entonces es muy difícil que tú te
informe de la actualidad de lo que está
pasando en venezuela a través del
teléfono bueno busco los twitter de las
personas que yo sé que te están diciendo
la verdad el whatsapp este me meto en
youtube las últimas horas pero siempre
buscando que sea la verdad porque no le
puedes dar credibilidad a todo lo que
salen en eso en esas redes
muchos periodistas y ciudadanos han
recurrido en la instalación de vpn en
sus computadoras para evadir el bloqueo
de portales sin embargo las continuas
fallas en el servicio eléctrico y la
difícil conexión a internet
especialmente en el interior del país
limitan aún más el derecho a la
información hasta aquí esta edición del
ac andino recuerden que pueden
sintonizarnos a través del
www.cuatro.com